foreign
Natural Selections this last week I
wrote a bit about dominance hierarchies
and gender Norms in humans the week
before I wrote about beavers and their
foundational role in uh in basically
architecting the Landscapes of North
America and the ecosystems of of North
America and yesterday
we dropped an episode uh on the same
topic in which you were talking to the
wonderful Jacob Shockey who is a former
student of ours and a friend of ours and
you had an almost three hour
conversation almost three hour
conversation and then as you know
um Jacob stuck around and we did some
fun stuff but it turned out there was
just a whole lot of stuff that he had to
say about beavers that uh is gonna have
to wait for a volume two because you
know absolutely there's there's some
very interesting stuff that didn't make
it into the podcast yeah and I haven't
listened to the entire podcast yet I did
read the piece that I wrote on account
of having written it and you know a
couple of the the points that have stuck
with me specifically are
um the mitigating effect on loss of
biodiversity and on extreme weather and
climate conditions like drought and
flood and fire especially in the
American West and then all also the fact
that and I know that you talked about
this in your conversation with Jacob as
well in the Dark Horse podcast that
dropped yesterday but that the the
beaver Trappers were so successful at
what they did and still to this day the
Beavers that remain are very docile so
it's interesting that they that the
beaver trap the Intensive Beaver
trapping over hundreds of years did not
have the selective effect on the
behavior on the personality of beavers
that you might expect that they remain
sort of easy to approach in many regards
but they were effectively eradicated
through so much of the American West
that when the eminent naturalist
Grinnell
came through in the I think it was the
1930s
his Natural History notes from his tour
of the American West basically framed
you know put into place an expectation
among ecologists of what of what we were
trying to recover to
which of course is always a dicey
proposition you know aiming aiming for a
single moment in a shifting over both
space and time landscape but he saw
Grinnell saw so so little beavers that
even so few beavers yeah depending on if
it's a collective noun or not
um and you know like us did not infer
from the landscape that what he was
seeing was extraordinary evidence of an
abundance of beavers throughout you know
many many tens of thousands at least of
years the ghost of beavers past yes that
he he said you know he he basically made
a number of claims based on what he saw
but he then made inference that was
wrong and from that we have historical
range maps that are inaccurate because
they're based on this great naturalist
who was normally so good at what he did
but even even he did not see through
basically the fog of time
so I wanted to add one thing to that so
uh probably because beavers were trapped
primarily
um the
REM the remnant of their approachability
might uh not be a strong indicator of
how selected they were by that
interaction and in fact
um well actually this runs a little bit
counter to what I just said but what I
learned from Jacob after the podcast
was that although it has been generally
our experience you're in mine and
generally accepted by most people who
talk about beavers in a scientific
context
that they are nocturnal that there's
actually good reason to think that that
is a switch that they have moved into a
nocturnal Niche presumably to avoid
people
um and that the evidence for this which
is because Trappers are lazy or because
not all Brokers go nocturnal at once and
so you know you you evade the Trappers
yeah but also just because we're diurnal
and so we're not as good at hunting at
night
um so anyway you hobble lazy for good
reason yeah right lazy is a matter of
self-preservation in large measure but
um but the lack of the tapedum lucidum
in the eye that is the reflective
surface that causes nocturnal animal's
eyes to shine if you ever shine a
flashlight at a dog at night you see the
eyes shine back that absence suggests
that this was not in initially
um a nocturnal creature and it's
interesting I know another story where a
creature has
um
moved into
diurnality by the same mechanism which
is a very strange thing for the same
reason for the same reason and this is
um the one and only example of a bat
that is diurnal that bat appears to have
been nocturnal in origin but it is
hunted by people in the roost and so it
pays to be out when people are up doing
their hunting so just this is a macro or
Mega whatever mega mega character so
this is one of the like flying foxes
this is one of these big beefy bats that
actually would provide you know
sustenance for a family of humans as
opposed to these little micro bits that
we've got here in the new world more of
a snack bat yeah this is a full meal bat
all right I take it back but in any case
interesting that uh beavers do appear to
have been modified in this way and it
hasn't seemed it hasn't changed their
approachability so much but it has
changed the likelihood of an encounter
based on them being primarily nocturnal
although I will say
at least two of the instances in which
I've seen beavers it was during the day
right
um one in Oaks bottom down in Portland
and one you and I saw a beaver I want to
say Eastern Washington somewhere yeah it
was it was in the Cascades uh very
interesting animal that we get we got to
watch quite a bit I was also reminded of
a
um that's funny uh I found Jacob during
the podcast talked a little bit about
the fact that his first encounter with a
beaver had been at the bus stop at the
loop at Evergreen that one had trundled
by and we had both remarked he'd never
seen a beaver before that I don't think
so even though he interesting even where
he grew up that's interesting and uh
anyway his point was he should have
followed it because what the hell was it
doing there there's no obvious reason
for a beaver to be there and then as I
was falling asleep last night I realized
that there was a there was a an episode
in my teaching at Evergreen where I
didn't see a beaver but I was biking
along the bike path on the main road
there
um and I saw a beaver sign right I saw a
place where beavers had chewed some
sticks and it's in a little Culvert
right no place that a beaver could
possibly hope to create any kind of
useful uh Pond and I had I had brought
my students and my co-faculty there and
they disbelieved me that it was real and
so anyway Jacob's observation of a
beaver you know what would be a block
and a half from where I found Beaver
sign is
um interesting there for whatever reason
they're active up on the road there yeah
no and I actually think
no one else will know the particular
geography of the area around Evergreen
but yeah I actually am remembering areas
that now now that I think on it feel
feel beautiful to me yeah and in fact
there is one uh across that road
um there's a there is a wetland that is
otherwise inexplicable yeah that's it
uh so so check both of those things out
check out uh the podcast uh the Dark
Horse podcast from yesterday and uh my
Natural Selections piece from two weeks
ago and uh will continue hopefully we'll
have Jacob back and um and we'll
continue talking about this
foreign
[Music]